we're told that Pierre has 48 minutes
until he needs to get ready for his
dance lesson graph how many minutes he
can spend playing with his pet before
getting ready if you are so inspired I
encourage you to be so inspired pause
the video and see if you can work
through that
all right now let's think through this
together so first of all we before I
even graph it I could say let's say that
m is how many minutes he is playing with
his pet before getting ready so let's
just call that's what m is going to be
equal to it's how many minutes he spends
and so how would M relate to the 48
minutes well he has 48 minutes so he can
spend anywhere from zero up to and
including 48 minutes so you might say m
is less than 48 but it's not just less
than it could even be exactly 48 minutes
as long as immediately after that he
gets ready for his dance lesson so m is
less than or equal to 48 so if I were to
put that on a number line let me
construct a number line like this
and
let me put this at zero right over here
let's say this is 10
30.
60 keep going this could be 70. this is
going to be essentially the values of M
that are going to be okay as long as
he's prepared for his dance lesson m is
less than or equal to 48. so what we can
do is we can go to 48 which is let's see
this would be 45 so 48 is going to be
right around there so that's 48 and
since it can be equal to 48 we're going
to fill in the circle if it just said
purely less than 48 but not less than or
equal then we put an open circle here
but because it's less than or equal to
we're going to include 48 right over
there I'll write the number 48 to make
it clear what that is and less than or
equal to so it's going to be all the
values less than that and so it would
look something
it would look something like this I'm
doing that light blue color it would
look something like then like that and
if we wanted to be clear that we're
including zero we could actually put a
dot here as well it wouldn't make sense
to go and include negative values as
well but let's do another example a
different example
so here we are told that the Harris
family needs to heat their leftover
gumbo to a minimum of 74 degrees Celsius
to be sure it is safe to eat graft
temperatures to which they could heat
their food so that it is safe to eat so
once again pause this video and see if
you could think about that before we do
this together
all right well let's imagine
let's see maybe we'll say tea for
temperature
so t for temperature and let's say t is
the temperature that they heat to
temperature that they Heat their gumbo
to that they heat too and now let's do a
number line we see well before I even do
the number line let me express it as
some kind of an inequality so they need
to a minimum of 74 degrees Celsius so
that means it has to be at least 74 or
higher
so that means T is not just greater than
74 degrees Celsius it can also be
exactly 74 degrees Celsius because it
says as long as it's a minimum of 74. so
if it's exactly 74 that is apparently
going to be safe to eat and anything
higher than that is also going to be
safe to eat at some point you can get to
such a high temperature that you
essentially turn your food into Ash it
might not be a delicious gumbo anymore
but it'll probably be safe to eat if
you're just eating gumbo powder of some
gumbo Ash I guess actually I'm not sure
if that's safe to eat but let's just
assume it is I don't recommend doing
that but let's put this on the number
line
so let me and actually here actually let
me let me do it in white so that I can
in that reddish color I can actually put
the values that we care about
and we can have negative temperature if
we're talking about degrees Celsius so
let's say that this is
zero degrees this is 10 20 30.
70. let me label that one that's 70
degrees this would be 80 degrees right
over here if we wanted to this would be
negative 10 negative 20. and we have to
be greater than or equal to 74 degrees
celsius if we would just had T is
greater than 74 degrees Celsius we would
go to 74 which would be right around
there we put an open circle and then we
would go greater than that so that's if
T was strictly greater than 74 degrees
Celsius but it's greater than or equal
to and so because of that we are going
to fill in this dot right over there and
to be clear that dot is at 74 degrees
and we're done